i'm buying and selling virtual space
owning the land that i can't have in
real life makes me feel great
[Music]
we've all heard about the metaverse a
virtual universe that blends aspects of
digital technologies with virtual
reality what is the metaverse the
metaphase jump into the metaverse
metaverse
now it's become a hot property market
with investors putting in millions of
dollars
south korea is one of the biggest
players in the metaverse market
and it's being championed by young
people who have had enough of the
economic inequality so they're looking
to make money in the alternate universe
instead
meet hyungwook and turgoon there are two
users in seoul i spoke to that have been
investing in one of the platforms called
metaverse 2 which aims to recreate earth
digitally
thanks for having us on the metaverse so
which part of the world do you own on
this metaverse platform
i have land in both new york and south
korea whereabouts in new york do you own
yoga so
i have a lot of land in new york and i
have a street vendor selling hot dogs on
wall street here
when the metaverse gets more developed i
plan to open a hot dog store
i also bought an island for some private
leisure time it's a park-like island
called mill rock park just on the right
side of manhattan rather than buying for
investment i'm mainly buying what i want
to have buying areas that can tell a
story there are so many people actually
buying this like empty water
with future updates we will be able to
mine some resources in the sea and in
the mountains
with that resource you can later
construct a building so many users are
buying parcels of ocean river and
mountain
the part where i feel the biggest gap
between the metaverse and the real world
is the financial area
hyungwook made over 40 000 us dollars in
just two months through his investments
in the metaverse 2 platform
you can just sit tight and earn interest
income of about three thousand to five
thousand dollars every month but that's
the salary i earn by working so hard on
my day job
in the south korean capital where almost
half of the country's population lives
the average price of an apartment has
doubled in the past five years reaching
over 950 000 by july 2021.
president moon jae-in's real estate
policies have seen the average price of
an apartment in seoul rise by around 90
since he took office
my parents generation is worried saying
why do young people try to make money so
easily isn't this gambling i think the
reason why millennials and gen z are so
drawn to the metaverse is that it is
very difficult to find a job right now
and house prices are preposterously high
you can never buy a house with your
salary
south koreans were the most active users
with around 9.1 million dollars spending
on a metaverse platform earth 2.
if you look at the infrastructure engine
it is true that many companies like
equinox in the us or amazon with its
data center north american companies are
far ahead in the meta first industry but
perhaps from the users or consumers
point of view it is true that korea has
a higher number of interested users
compared to its population
i think there are more users in south
korea because koreans are so accustomed
to high-speed internet they are so used
to this kind of media the internet and
the metaverse world
the initial real estate value of
metaverse 2 was 10 cents per tile for
all the land in seoul in new york
but now landmarks like seoul's latte
tower are priced at over ten thousand
dollars per tile and the statue of
liberty in new york is going for over
seven thousand dollars per tile
it's not just property
south korea's biggest companies have
also jumped into the metaverse
samsung unveiled the country's first
metaverse themed etfs in october last
year and neighbors metaverse platform
zapedo has over 200 million users
globally
sk group is planning on issuing a coin
for its metaverse platform ifland
the government is also backing the
metaverse as a part of its digital new
deal the government pledged to provide
up to 26 million dollars this year
i predict original technology will be
developed through this new jobs will be
created and games that support the
country's important educational
functions or businesses will develop
innovatively
but professor kim has some concerns
the current virtual real estate market
does not have a present value it is
market where we buy and sell among
ourselves based on its future value
since this market has yet not been able
to prove its present value i consider
this part to be risky
being immersed in a small five-inch
smartphone screen or putting a vr
headset on people over 50 are
uncomfortable with this
this could be a means of creating
another digital divide in the end
the reason young people are jumping into
the metaverse while knowing its risk is
because they want to make profit in the
past there was only the stock market or
gold but now the metaverse is in the
spotlight as a new form of investment i
think this is the new reality not an
illusion
technologists say the metaverse will be
more integrated into our lives and grow
into a fully functioning immersive
economy
in the future all economic and daily
activities will occur simultaneously in
the metaverse and in real life
[Music]
the power is collapsing in a place where
time and space could be physically
controlled young people rise up against
this crumbling power and many tables
will be turned in all industries
[Music]